in the foothills of Albania's Alps the
remote town of Hass so many people have
migrated from Hass to the UK in recent
years there's some people like Naim feel
left behind what he calls a ghost town
he tried to reach Britain from France
himself a few years ago by hiding in a
lorry but he didn't make it
everyone I know is in the UK including
all my friends from high school there
was a time when I really wanted to go
too to see what it's like but now maybe
I'd rather just visit
it's not easy for albanians to get UK
work visas but a growing network of
traffickers have made it possible to
cross the English Channel from France
illegally by small boat it's dangerous
but young people like bugar say they
have no choice Albania is stable but
poverty and Corruption are widespread
jobs and opportunities scarce
most people have made it by boat as they
can't get a Visa as for me I don't have
a Visa so what am I supposed to do I'll
have no choice I'll have to take a boat
because there is nothing for us there's
no work people began migrating from a
house in the 1990s after the end of
Communism in Albania many ended up in
Britain creating a network of jobs and
connections that paved the way for
others going to the UK has become
something of a tradition in-house it
feels familiar in a way that other
countries don't there are reminders of
the UK everywhere in Hassan some of the
names of the cafes and restaurants all
the fact that some of the cars have
British license plates the city council
is even considering building a statue of
the queen funded by some of the money
that albanians are sending home the
statue is the mayor's idea he jokes that
Hass is almost a London suburb he says
people are grateful for the wealth
generated by migration to Britain it
fuels the local economy but the
dwindling young population is a problem
for the town I discarded the Region's
roads are so dilapidated that it's
difficult to reach many villages it's
impossible for people to live in these
areas so the only option they have is to
migrate there is simply a lack of
effective policies or investment from
the central government to keep people in
Albania the British government says
Albania is a safe country it's planning
tighter laws to stop illegal Albanian
arrivals once described by Britain's
home minister as an invasion Tehran has
accused London of whipping up
anti-albanian sentiment but the UK's
approach may not deter some people who
say they have little to lose and want a
chance for a better life Natasha Butler
Al Jazeera Hass Albania